>>> RIGHT NOW OSING ARGUMENTS
UNDER WAY IN E. JEAN CARROLL'S
TTERY AND DEFAMATION TRIAL
AGNST DONALD TRUMP.
THE JURY EXPECTED TO START ITS
DELIBERATIONS TOMORROW AFTER
HEARING FROM 11 WITNESSES
INCLUDING THE WRITER HERSELF.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HOWEVER
OPTED NOT TO TESTIFY, INSTEAD
YOU CAN SEE IT THERE, JURORS DID
SEE CLIPS OF HIS VIDEO
DEPOSITION FROM LAST YEAR
FIELDING QUESTIONS.
LET'S GO LIVE TO CARA OUTSIDE
THE COURTHOUSE IN NEW YORK CITY.
WALK US THROUGH, WHAT ARE THE
REVELATIONS TODAY?
>> Reporter: CLOSING ARGUMENTS
UNDER WAY.
E. JEAN CARROLL'S ATTORNEYS
STARTED OFF, HER ATTORNEY WENT
ABOUT 90 MINUTES AND TOLD THE
JURY IN THE COURTROOM IN THIS
U.S. JUSTICE SYSTEM NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW, NOT EVEN A FORMER
PRESIDENT TELLING THEM THEIR JOB
WAS TO SEE THAT JUSTICE WAS
DONE.
CARROLL'S ATTORNEY POINTED OUT
TRUMP DIDN'T BOTHER TO SHOW UP
AND SAYING DONALD TRUMP'S OWN
WORDS THE WORDS FROM THE VIDEO
DEPOSITION, ACTUALLY HELP HER
CASE.
THEY ARGUED THAT TRUMP HAD
MISTAKEN HIS E. JEAN CARROLL FOR
HIS FORMER WIFE MARLA MAPLES,
BEING SHOWN A PHOTO OF THEM AND
POINT TOGETHER "ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD" TAPE WHICH THEY
REPLAYED BEFORE THE JURY SAYING
OVERLAYING WHAT TRUMP SAID ON
THAT TAPE, I JUST KISS WOMEN
WHEN I SEE THEM WITH E. JEAN
CARROLL'S ALLEGATIONS OF BEING
RAPED IN BERGDORF GOODMAN'S
DEPARTMENT STORE.
TRUMP SAYING HE JUST GRABS WOMEN
DETAILING HOW RAPED E. JEAN
CARROLL AND TRUMP SAYING STARS
GET AWAY WITH IT UNFORTUNATELY
OR FORTUNATELY AND SAYING HE IS
A STAR.
SHE TOLD THE JURY TO FOCUS ON
THAT AND THE ALLEGATIONS BROUGHT
BY THE TWO OTHER WOMEN WHO
TESTIFIED IN THE CASE SAYING
THAT IS TRUMP'S M.O., TO ASSAULT
WOMEN IN SEMI PUBLIC PLACES AND
WHEN THEY GO PUBLIC TO DENY AND
ATTACK THEM.
YOU KNOW, SHE ALSO SAID THAT,
YOU KNOW, IF THEY REALLY WANTED
TO KNOW WHO WAS TELLING THE
TRUTH IN THIS CASE, THAT THEY
SHOULD LISTEN TO TRUMP'S WORDS
GOING BACK AGAIN TO THE "ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD" TAPE SAYING THIS IS
WHAT HE MEANT WHEN HE SAID IT
AND THOUGHT IT WAS A PRIVATE
CONVERSATION ON THE "ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD" BUS, NOT SOMETHING HE
IS ASKED TO SAY IN A VIDEO
DEPOSITION NOW, SO SAYING THAT
IF THEY THINK ANYONE IN THIS
CASE IS LYING IT'S DONALD TRUMP
AND TO BELIEVE TRUMP'S VERSION
OF EVENTS, THEY ARGUE, YOU HAVE
TO BELIEVE EVERY OTHER WITNESS
IN THIS CASE WAS LYING.
>> TO THAT POINT PLAY A BIT OF
THE DEPOSITION BECAUSE, AGAIN,
FOR PEOPLE AT HOME, I APOLOGIZE
THESE ARE DONALD TRUMP'S WORDS
NOT MY WORDS BUT SAID REPEAT LID
THAT E. JEAN CARROLL IS NOT HIS
TIME.
TO UNDERMINE IN THAT DEPOSITION
THE LAWYERS WERE QUESTIONING HIM
AND CAUGHT HIM SAYING THIS.
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THE
WOMAN -- LET'S SEE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO -- IT'S MARLA.
>> YOU SAY MARLA IS IN THIS
PHOTO?
>> THAT'S MARLA, YEAH.
THAT'S MY WIFE.
>> WHICH ONE ARE YOU POINTING
TO?
>> HERE.
>> THAT'S CARROLL.
>> THE PERSON YOU POINTED TO IS
E. JEAN CARROLL.
>> HE SAYS HE DOESN'T KNOW HER,
NEVER MET HER AND A PHOTO
INTRODUCED FROM A PARTY AT THE
1980s.
IF YOU JUST SAW THIS PHOTO MAYBE
YOU FORGET THAT BUT THEN YOU
HAVE THE MOMENT IN THE
DEPOSITION AND YET DESPITE ALL
THAT, TRUMP'S LAWYERS DECIDED
NOT TO CALL HIM OR HE DID NOT
WANT TO COME IN AS A WITNESS,
DECIDING THEY WOULD TAKE THEIR
CHANCE TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO SWAY
TWO JURORS, IS THAT MATH RIGHT?
>> IT'S A JURY OF SIX MEN AND
THREE WOMEN AND FOR IT TO GET A
VERDICT IN THIS CASE IT HAS TO
BE UNANIMOUS.
THEY NEED TO PERSUADE ONE OR TWO
PEOPLE THAT CARROLL'S
ALLEGATIONS ARE WRONG SO THAT
THERE'S NOT A UNANIMOUS VERDICT.
IT'S THE BURDEN OF PROOF ON
CARROLL'S TEAM.
THEY HAVE TO PROVE THIS CASE.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF BECAUSE IT
IS A CIVIL CASE IS LOWER THAN A
CRIMINAL CASE.
PY THE PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE.
IF YOU BELIEVE IT MORE THAN 50%